من فكره هامشيه الى توجه العسكري جديد
كوريا الجنوبيه تغير خطتها بشان امتلاك
القوه النوويه
متى هاجس التسلح النووي ليتعلق بالامن
القومي فقط بل توجه ان يرغب فيه المواطنون
والمسؤولون على حد سوا
حسب
الامريكيه يتعلق الامر بشعور الكوريين
الجنوبيين بالحاجه الى حمايه انفسهم من
جار شمالي عدواني خاصه مع تعاهد الزعيم
الكوري الشمالي
النوويه
يتوازن مع رغبه داخليه في كوريا الجنوبيه
من استقلاليه الامنيه بعيدا عن الولايات
المتحده حيث تشعر الصلب
نفسها في حال نشوب حرب النوويه
سواء كانت لديهم اسلحه نوويه او اي نوع من
اسلحه الدمار يجب ان نرسل رساله واضحه لاي
شخص يستفزنا باننا لن نخاف ولن نتردد
رغم ان الرسول تخضع لاستراتيجيه الردع
الموسعه لوشنطن التي تشمل المظله النوويه
والتي تلزم الولايات المتحده بمساعدتها في
حال وقوع هجوم لكن الشكل المحدد الذي قد
تتخذه المساعده ليس واضحه الامر الذي يوفر
قلق المواطنين بشكل كبير خاصه مع تناقض
مواقف واشنطن
في حين تقول كوريا الجنوبيه
مع الولايات المتحده الى ان الاخيره تنفيذ
ذلك
المظله نوويه الامريكيه التي توفرها
واشنطن لبلادنا لم تعد كافيه لطمئنه
المواطنين الكوريين الجنوبيين حتى مع
الضمادات التي قد تقدمها الولايات المتحده
لتمرده كوريا الجنوبيه
الصول لديها مخاوف اعمق تتعلق بتغير
توجهات الادارات الامريكيه
المتعاقبه ورغبه عميقه بالتخلص منها هاجس
القلق الامني او ويصبح امنها حبيسا
لرغبات دول اخرى